what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and this morning the case for Jonathan
majors has begun most people know that
Jonathan Majors not too long ago was
arrested he was charged with some
assault cases and more against his
girlfriend at the time who which we have
recently found out actually worked on
the set of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania but this morning he appeared
in court virtually in the Manhattan
District Attorney's office and they made
a public superseding complaint with a
charge of third degree assault so that
is what he is facing right now a
misdemeanor and it has a maximum
possible sentence of up to 12 months a
year behind bars or a three-year
probation term so right now
unfortunately Jonathan Majors could not
will not until the hearing is done but
could possibly go to prison for a year
we have an account from deadline of what
exactly happened this morning with the k
case of Jonathan majors in court so
we're going to read it from deadline
we're going to get the koltar facts then
we're gonna break it down and this is
coming straight from deadline's website
straight from the courthouse so this is
not rumors this is not coming from TMZ
it's an actual account of what happened
today during court and it's pretty
interesting because apparently according
to his lawyer he has a lot more evidence
that has recently come out with video
proof but we'll get into that as we go
over what happened here so here is what
deadline said barely visible to the
gallery on screens facing away from the
seats Majors Jonathan Majors did not
enter a plea to the new charge in fact
dressed in a beige shirt and against a
pale off-white background on screen
Majors had little to say Tuesday Beyond
yes ma'am to judge Rachel s Paulie the
next Hearing in the matter has been set
for June 13th the judge told Majors he
has to appear in person for that she
said I'm required to inform you that as
you know if you fail to appear in court
on June 13th a warrant can be issued for
your arrest within 48 hours and if
you're brought back on the warrant the
next judge can revoke and even set bail
I obviously don't want that to happen
additionally judge Paulie reminded the
conference in Majors that he must abide
by the order of protection barring him
from any contact with the woman in
question outside of court today Majors
as lawyer Priya Chaudhary was blistering
in her assessment of the DA's case she
stated we have provided the district
attorney with irrefutable evidence that
the woman is lying including video proof
showing nothing happened especially
where she claimed the lawyer continued
to State we did this with the explicit
promise from the D.A that they would not
fix their case and change it as we
proved the woman is lying this is a
Witch Hunt against Jonathan Majors
driven by baseless claims
his lawyer went on to say citing a
glaring double standard in a statement
directly to deadlines stating instead of
dismissing the allegations in the face
of the woman's clear lies the D.A has
adjusted the charges to match the
woman's new lies to be clear there are
no new charges against Mr Majors without
providing any details she added this now
we have obtained even more video
evidence of his innocence but we are
hesitant to share it or fear the D.A
will tip the woman off to change her
story again the criminal justice system
is saturated with explicit and implicit
bias when Mr may just showed a white
police officer the injuries the woman
caused him the white officer got in Mr
majors's face and taunted him saying
that if the officer were to slap Mr
Majors the officer wouldn't break his
finger none of the white officers
present investigated the assault of Mr
Majors worse the district attorney has
not indicated any intention to pursue
charges against the woman or even
investigate the truth and for those of
you who may not be aware the woman
stated that he broke her finger but
Jonathan major stated that she was
actually the one assaulting him slapping
him so basically what the officer was
saying here is you can't break your
finger by slapping somebody if he were
to slap Jonathan Majors he's not gonna
break his finger Jonathan Majors was
essentially saying she slapped me but
she was saying her finger was broken
because of him basically stating he
assaulted her and in that process broke
her finger so essentially they were
saying that immediately from when the
police got on the scene they were biased
against Jonathan majors and against him
and for the woman let's go ahead and
finish this article because it gets
everybody up to speed on just everything
that is happening right now
professionally with Jonathan majors's
life including his work with Marvel
deadline states that in the time between
his arrest on March 25th and today
Majors as previously high-flying career
trajectory has been in a tailspin while
still on board for the completed season
2 of Marvel's Loki and upcoming Avengers
movies so far the actor has been dropped
by managers 360 Entertainment and PR
team the lid company majors has lost at
least one movie role as well as at least
two ad campaigns still represented by
WME the actor has faced rumors of other
incidents and inappropriate behavior but
no one or any concrete evidence has
emerged on that front and this is true
the moment that he got arrested a bunch
of people on Twitter that apparently
worked with them before came out and
kind of said that he wasn't exactly the
best person however like deadline says
they offered no actual evidence for
their claims deadline States what is on
the police record is a complaint from
the DA's office on Majors on March 25th
striking the woman about the face with
an open hand causing substantial pain
and a laceration behind the ear and what
the NYPD later called a domestic dispute
Majors allegedly forcefully took the
woman's hand causing swelling bruising
and substantial pain to her finger and
supposedly put his hand on her neck
in the superseding information submitted
today the neck reference was gone but
the DA's paperwork now also said I
further observed the defendant grabbed
my right arm placed it behind my body
and used his hands to twist my right
forearm and right middle finger causing
substantial pain to my right forearm and
right middle finger so basically the
woman took back what she said about his
hand being on her neck and changed the
story to add something new about him
grabbing the arm and also grabbing her
middle finger which is not the finger
she said before it ends by stating
citing text messages and security camera
footage from the end of March majors's
lawyer Chaudhary has repeatedly
reiterated her clients initial not
guilty plea and insisted that he is the
victim here not the aggressor it has
been confirmed by law enforcement that
it was Majors who called 9-1-1 the night
of the incident late last month majors's
team agreed to a Full temporary order of
protection being granted for the woman
in question from the March 25th incident
this is the standard in cases such as
this and we consented because Mr Majors
wants nothing to do with the woman who
assaulted him his lawyer told deadline
on April 27th like today the lawyer has
previously criticized the NYPD officers
on the scene that night at Majors
apartment chadre his lawyer claims the
cops were coaching the alleged victim to
accuse Mr majors of assault even
pantomiming what she should say and the
last line that deadline States in this
article says whether that comes up in
the motion the defense filed today to be
discussed at next month's hearing
remains to be seen so essentially
Jonathan Majors his lawyer and his team
are arguing that this woman was being
coached by the police on what exactly to
say to make it look better for her to
press charges against Jonathan majors
and as deadline stated she kind of
changed her story it went from her
saying that he broke her finger and
grabbed her neck to her saying that he
grabbed her arm and put it behind her
back and he bruised her middle finger
which is a different finger so chaudry
Jonathan Majors his lawyer is
essentially saying that this is kind of
a Witch Hunt and they are simply out to
get Jonathan Majors she also claimed as
you heard that they provided irrefutable
evidence meaning they should have enough
evidence presented to the court that
Jonathan Majors actually did nothing
wrong and the police even confirmed that
he was the one who called 9-1-1 about
the situation because he was allegedly
getting assaulted by her they also had
testimonies from the cab driver and
people outside of the cab when he got
out as well she also says they have even
more evidence but they are afraid to
present it to the court because they are
afraid that they are going to once again
coach the woman who is the alleged
victim in this situation to kind of
change her story around this evidence so
again we're trying to remain impartial
here we're simply waiting for the final
Court decision but it does sound like
Jonathan majors does have a lot of
evidence however it does seem like
things are kind of against him right now
and he could base up to a year in prison
if things don't work out his way and he
gets found guilty of these charges if he
gets found guilty of these charges
Marvel Studios will most likely have to
drop him as king the Conqueror and
recast him especially considering he'll
be in prison for a year so right now
it's just a waiting game to see what
happens on the next court date but of
course if we hear anything else in the
meantime we'll be sure to do an update
video so be sure to subscribe and click
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos we also
have a giveaway right now where we're
giving away a PS5 and Xbox series X
Marvel Legends items and some DC items
as well all you got to do to enter
subscribe to the channel leave comments
on our videos we pick a winner at the
end of each month at random you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
baby